after the new york post runs a bombshell
story about hunter biden brokering a
meeting between a ukrainian oligarch and
joe biden
facebook and twitter crack down on the
story we examine our intrepid
journalists who continuously cheer
censorship
and amy coney barrett moves one step
closer to confirmation i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
my savvy fans secure their internet join
them at expressvpn.com by the way one of
the reasons you should secure your
internet is that social media giants
cannot control the information
that you see and hear as easily and that
is the topic
of today's show i mean this is
unbelievable
unbelievable so yesterday late morning
early afternoon
the new york post breaks a story about
hunter biden
and joe biden and essentially the story
is this
hunter biden who is in fact a crackhead
i mean he is
he is a drug addict uh he is an unsavory
character
he has several he he has
had many affairs with various different
uh
women he's he's a mess hunter hunter
biden is just a mess he's a mess of a
human being
and that's not joe's fault per se i mean
there are lots of good parents who have
messes for children but it is joe's
fault that joe has allowed hunter biden
to run across the world picking up sacks
of cash
by trading on his last name and that is
what hunter biden has been doing for
years where he picked up sacks of cash
in china they picked up stacks of cash
in ukraine and for a long time
conservatives have been focused in
on hunter biden's activities with regard
to burisma
now the original narrative with regard
to burisma's bharisma zaden is a
natural gas and oil company in ukraine
hunter biden was sitting on the board of
that company and picking up checks for
000 a month despite the fact that he
didn't know anything about natural gas
or oil
despite the fact that he himself was a
personal mess
the only reason he was on that board is
because he was related to joe biden
joe biden was then the vice president of
the united states and largely in charge
of ukrainian policy
well joe biden then bragged on tape
about getting one of the
chief prosecutors over in ukraine fired
he's threatened to withhold one billion
dollars in foreign h ukraine until they
fired this guy
joe biden always claimed that it had
nothing to do with hunter this
prosecutor claimed that he was about to
investigate berezima that was the
company hunter was working for
the the chain has never quite been made
so there's a lot of controversy over the
vic
over whether victor shuken who was that
prosecutor was actually going to
prosecute bharisma
there was indeed a lot of focus on
victor shulkin as a possible corrupt
figure
inside ukraine a lot of people in europe
wanted to see victor shoken go as the
chief prosecutor
in ukraine biden has always claimed that
his firing of victor victor shoken was
on the
up and up shokin has always claimed that
it was corrupt that controversy has been
out there for
quite a while what is unchallenged is
that
joe biden's family members ranging from
his brother to
his son use his name in order to make
money for themselves
and that does have an element of
corruption to it
now the best that you can say about it
is that joe biden turned a blind eye to
it
right and this is sort of what joe has
argued joe biden has said well i didn't
know about it
nobody ever did anything nobody ever did
anything man nobody come on man come on
i never knew no come on okay so here is
the bombshell
yesterday the new york post reports that
hunter biden actually brokered a meaning
between a ukrainian oligarch who was a
burisma
chief member and joe biden directly
that's what one of these emails tended
to suggest so here's the story from the
new york post
hunter biden introduced his father then
vice president joe biden to a top
executive at a ukrainian energy firm
less than a year before the elder biden
pressured government officials into
ukraine
into in in ukraine into firing a
prosecutor who is investigating the
company according to emails
obtained by the post the never before
revealed meeting is mentioned in a
message of appreciation that vadim
posharskiye
an advisor to the board of burisma
allegedly sent hunter biden on april 17
2015 about a year after hunter joined
the barisma board at a reported salary
of up to 50 grand a month
the email reads dear hunter thank you
for inviting me to dc and giving an
opportunity to meet your father and
spend some time together
it's really an honor and a pleasure an
earlier email from may 2014
also shows pusharskai reportedly
berezman's number three exec
asking hunter for advice on how you
could use your influence on the
company's behalf
the blockbuster correspondence as the
new york post reports flies in the face
of joe biden's claim that he has never
spoken to my son about his overseas
business dealings
it's contained in a massive trove of
data recovered from a laptop computer
the computer was dropped off apparently
at a repair shop in biden's home state
of delaware in april 2019
according to the store's owner other
material extracted from the computer
includes a raunchy 12-minute video that
appears to show hunter who's admitted
struggling with addiction problems
smoking crack
while engaged in a sex act with an
unidentified woman as well as numerous
other sexually explicit images
the customer who brought in the water
damage macbook pro for a pair never paid
for the service or retrieved it
or a hard drive on which its contents
were stored according to the shop owner
who said he tried repeatedly to contact
the client the shop owner couldn't
positively identify the customer as
hunter biden but said that the laptop
bore a sticker from the beau biden
foundation
named after hunter's late brother and
former delaware attorney general
photos of a delaware federal subpoena
given to the post show that both the
computer and hard drive was seized by
the fbi in december
after the shop's owner says he alerted
the feds to their existence
before turning over the gear according
to the shop owner he made a copy of the
hard drive and later gave it to former
mayor rudy giuliani's lawyer robert
costello
steve bannon the former advisor to
president trump told the post about the
existence of the hard drive
in late september giuliani provided the
post with a copy of it on sunday
less than eight months after pajarska
thanked hunter biden for the
introduction to his dad
the then vice president admittedly
pressured ukrainian president petro
poroshenko and prime minister arsene
yatsenyuk into getting rid of prosecutor
general victor shuken by threatening to
withhold a 1 billion
u.s loan guarantee during a december
2015 trip to kiev
biden infamously bragged to the council
on foreign relations i looked at them
and said i'm leaving in six hours
if the prosecutor is not fired you're
not getting money well son of a
he got fired and so it is not necessary
to actually believe that joe biden got
choking fired to protect his son in
order to recognize that joe biden taking
meetings with people
that his son is picking up bags of cash
from who have influence
in areas over which joe biden had
influence that is not a good look
it may not be illegal but it is
certainly corrupt pete rose didn't have
to bet
on his own team in order for it to be a
bad thing that he was betting on
baseball
the clinton foundation did not actually
have to manifest
in hillary clinton doing things for the
various countries who were sending cash
to the clinton foundation
the fact that they had access to her was
the corruption
shogun has said that at the time of his
firing in march 2016
he'd made specific plans to investigate
burisma that included interrogations and
other crime
investigation procedures into all
members of the executive board including
hunter biden biden has insisted the us
wanted choking removed
over corruption concerns which were
shared by the european union
so as early as 2014 the emails show that
this
top person at burisma was urging hunter
biden to
use political leverage to help the
company
okay so that was the story okay and it's
a story i mean it's certainly a story
that joe biden apparently met with or
was planning to meet with
this barisma executive on behalf of
hunter biden
so that hunter could continue to traffic
with daddy's name
so the biden campaign released a
statement via andrew bates their
spokesman
they said investigations led by the
press during impeachment and even by two
republican-led senate committees whose
work was decried as not legitimate and
political by a gop colleague have all
reached the same conclusion
that joe biden carried out official u.s
policy toward ukraine and engaged in no
wrongdoing
trump administration officials have
attested to these facts under oath
the new york post never asked the biden
campaign about the critical elements of
the story
they certainly never raised that rudy
giuliani whose discredited conspiracy
theories and alliance with figures
connected to russian intelligence have
been widely reported
claimed to have such materials moreover
we have reviewed joe biden's official
schedules from the time and no meeting
as alleged by the new york post ever
took place okay so
that is a very carefully worded
statement the reason it's a very
carefully worded statement is it says
that it's not on the calendar
okay well lots of meetings happen
between people that are in fact not
on the calendar furthermore i do enjoy
it when democrats
start complaining and whining about
russian disinformation when they
literally trafficked in russian
disinformation for three long years
culminating
in an impeachment attempt against donald
trump okay the fact is that the mueller
report was largely predicated on the
steele dossier which was a piece of
russian disinformation
that was not only bought into it was
overtly trafficked by the hillary
clinton campaign via fusion gps to the
intel community this is unchallenged
okay so don't lecture us about russian
disinformation
when the fact is the democrats were
perfectly willing to accept russian
disinformation
and then and then jabber on about how
trump was on tape
asking people to pee on him and such
like that that just doesn't work
so it's a very carefully worded denial
from joe biden and then as it turns out
the denial doesn't actually mean
anything
because a little bit later in the day
politico reported quote biden's campaign
would not rule out the possibility
that the former vp had some kind of
informal interaction with pusharsky
which wouldn't appear on biden's
official schedule
they said any encounter would have been
cursory purchasing did not respond to a
request
for comment so now they're admitting oh
yeah by the way the the
meeting could have happened at no point
anywhere in here
at no point is there a denial that the
emails are real
that the emails are legit that they were
written by hunter biden or by pujarski
at no point does the biden campaign
actually deny a material fact of the
report
other than continuing to deny that biden
got this
prosecutor victor shuken fired in order
to protect hunter and barisma
that is the only part of the story that
they've denied they've not denied any of
the surrounding circumstances they've
not denied that a meeting
took place they have not denied that the
emails about the meeting are real
so the story is real okay the story is
correct
and senate republicans immediately
announced that they would launch an
investigation into all this we'll get
into that in one second it turns out
that the big story here is not in fact
this hunter biden story the big story
is how our social media bettors have
decided there's information you should
not see
and you should not hear and they are
doing it on a purely political basis
there is no question about this
i've been a big defender of freedom of
the internet i've been a big defender
against using legislation to crack down
on social media companies
it makes it very difficult for
conservatives to defend a laissez-faire
view of facebook and twitter
and various other social media companies
when they act as overt organs of the
democratic party and involve themselves
in censorship of mainstream media
outlets like the new york post because
they don't like the story
it makes it almost impossible i don't
think legislation
is the proper answer to this question i
don't think the government overseeing
facebook and twitter
and controlling what they can do is the
answer but i sure as hell don't trust
the people who are in charge over there
if this is the kind of activity in which
they're going to engage this is
egregious okay that's the actual story
here so the hunter biden story
that's bad but it's just the predicate
to the actual story here which is the
attempt to stop you the american people
from being able to access information
that you want
in an overt attempt to stop you from
seeing bad information about joe biden
in the three weeks running up to the
election
that's madness that's madness these
social media companies who purport to be
platforms
rather than publishers are now in the
business of censoring content
they do not like not on the basis of any
neutral
application of rules but on the basis of
absolutely non-neutral application of
rules we'll get to this in
one second first let's talk about the
fact
that you're spending way too much on
cable cable costs a fortune
why not get all the channels that you
want without cable this is why you need
fubo tv it's how you should be watching
tv in fact i haven't been paying for
cable tv for a long time and fubo makes
it possible for me to see the channels i
want
fubotv will bring you over 100 channels
cloud tvr no hidden fees you can stream
your shows on your tv or any other smart
device
they've got the major broadcast and
cable networks so you can find all your
favorite shows including live sports
news and primetime tv
with fubotv you get all your favorites
like this is us and the bachelor you get
the premier league and the nba next
season they'll get rid of the politics
all the news channels and so much more
there's no risk to try it out get full
access to fubotv for seven days for free
yes it does include
fox news for my listeners who love fox
news right now fubo tv is offering my
listeners the seven-day free trial
and 15 off your first month by going to
fubotv.com there are no contracts you
can cancel
anytime go to pen for fubotv.com
off your first month and a free trial
again that's fubotv.com
fubotv.com slash ben i've been using
fubo tv it's fantastic and again it's
going to cost you way less than cable so
just cut that cord
and get involved over at fubotv.com
ben to get 15 off your first month okay
so
the senate committee the senate
intelligence committee is now
announcing an investigation according to
the censor square u.s senator ron
johnson chairman of the senate homeland
security and governmental affairs
committee
said the committee will now be
investigating newly released emails
published by the new york post that
purport to reveal that hunter biden
introduced his dad joe biden
while he was vp of the united states to
an executive at ukrainian gas firm
barisma the emails contradict claims joe
has repeatedly made
to the media johnson told fox news the
committee was in contact with the source
of the emails quote
although we consider those
communications to be confidential
because the individual in this instance
spoke with the media about his contact
with the committee
we can confirm receipt of his email
complaint have been in contact with the
whistleblower and are in the process of
validating the information
he provided about two weeks ago the
senate committee announced the findings
of a year-long investigation into hunter
biden
after senator charles grassley of iowa
raised concerns about alleged corruption
linking hunter bite into millions of
dollars in transactions taking place
between barisma holding
russian oligarch elena batarina and
chinese businessmen with tai chi
beijing's communist government
joe biden has repeatedly said he knew
nothing about any of this
it is all it is all brand new to him he
did not know anything about any of this
and then as it turns out well not so
much
okay so the underlying issue is again
an issue of corruption the appearance of
corruption is certainly there
when the vice president of the united
states with power over ukraine policy is
meeting
with ukrainian oligarchs in charge of
natural oil and gas companies at the
behest of his son who's picking up bags
of cash
in ukraine from that company that does
not look good
senator john kennedy from louisiana he
pointed this out last night on fox news
president obama put vice president biden
in charge of america's foreign affairs
with two countries
ukraine and china and in both cases
his son mr hunter biden walked away
with millions of dollars of contracts
i'm not accusing anybody of anything but
i'm telling you this
this is the message it's sent to the
rest of the world
the foreign policy of the united states
of america
can be bought like a sack of potatoes
okay that is the impression that is put
out there in the same way that the
clinton foundation
which was receiving bags and bags and
bags of cash from foreign sources
during the years when hillary clinton
was secretary of state and then all the
funding magically dried up the minute
she was no longer secretary of state
gives that same appearance of
generalized corruption okay but that's
not the real story here
it isn't the real story here is the
social media reaction to this i have
never seen
anything remotely like this okay i've
been highly critical of twitter in
particular
for censoring material for booting
people for using fake
fact checks in order to target
particular stories in particular tweets
particularly from trump
i've been extremely critical of facebook
and their use of outside fact checkers
i did an entire episode on this just a
couple of weeks ago when facebook used
outside fact checkers to take down
two separate ads that were both true one
claiming that joe biden was going to
raise their taxes and the other claiming
that the equality act would make it
impossible for there to be
separate male and female sports if taken
literally
okay the the facebook took both of those
down based on garbage fact checks from a
garbage leftist
fact-checking site called politifact so
facebook has been attempting to remove
itself
from the business of determining what
material should be up or down instead
they outsourced it to a bunch of
outside fact checkers who all virtually
all of whom
happen to be left-wing fact-checkers who
have no interest in actually checking
facts
instead what they do is they will take a
statement that is perfectly true from a
conservative
and they will fact-check the
implications quote-unquote implications
things that nobody said and then they
will declare that a perfectly true
statement is false
and then facebook will censor the
material based on the outside fact
checkers
facebook has also set up a group it's
supposed to be a panel
like an appeals board on this sort of
stuff but that appeals board has not
gone into place yet so we have no idea
how that appeals board will rule
on particular cases so facebook has been
deliberately attempting to take itself
out of the business
of being directly responsible for
censorship by trying to outsource it
to various fact-checking groups
yesterday the mask came
completely off completely off for
facebook
and twitter never had a mask and so
twitter basically just decided okay well
you know what
we don't like the story about hunter
biden and joe biden it doesn't matter
that we have yet to
find an element of the story that is
overtly not true none of that matters
the only thing that matters is that this
story cannot go out
it cannot go out so twitter decided that
they were going to censor the story
so did facebook they both made it
impossible to distribute the link
you literally on twitter you literally
could not link the new york post story
if you tried to tweet out a link of the
new york post story a warning would come
up
if you did tweet out the new york post
story they suspended your account
the new york post main twitter account
was suspended
it was suspended you couldn't tweet from
the new york post twitter account
because of this story kaylee mcenany the
white house press secretary had her
twitter account suspended for tweeting
out
information from the new york post story
i mean this is crazy towns this is a
mainstream media
but new york post is a very mainstream
publication it is
okay nothing in the story is less well
sourced than a bevy of other stories the
mainstream media have run with
that are anti-trump does not matter both
facebook and twitter
cracked down on it and made it
impossible to distribute the story
that's an unbelievable breach of
whatever twitter and facebook were
supposed to be
if again the idea is that these are
platforms and that their job is to
provide an open forum for people to
disseminate information
particularly if the information is not
overtly false i mean again this is prior
to any fact check
the emails are real the allegations in
that hunter biden story whether you
think they're serious or not
is a secondary concern the bottom line
is this it appears that facebook
and twitter were so concerned with the
ramifications of a bad story going out
about hunter and joe biden
based on leaked emails that they shut
down the entire story
and there's only one reason for that the
only reason for that is because the
leftists at facebook
and the leftists at twitter and the
leftists in the journalistic
establishment
have decided that it is time to shut
down the dissemination of information
they do not like
okay this is a threat to the republic i
don't think hunter biden and joe behind
are threats to the republic
i do think that social media becoming a
tool of one side to the extent that they
are now
openly censoring what material can be
disseminated
informational journalism they're
shutting it down you want to talk to me
about trumping a threat to the press
trump isn't one iota the threat of the
press that social media are when they
decide that you cannot publish a story
that reflects negatively on joe biden
that's insanity
perfect insanity and people should be
leaving these services in droves if
these are the standards
that are going to be put forth by these
social media companies
again i've been very hesitant to talk
about big tech as sort of a monolithic
leftist entity
well yesterday they acted as a
monolithic leftist entity without any
attempt to pretend
that they were enforcing anything
remotely resembling a neutral rule
that's that's madness we'll get to more
of this in one second i mean i am
i'm enraged by this and you should be
enraged by this too
honestly left right or center you should
be enraged by the idea that these social
media companies
will literally stop the dissemination of
a story because they don't like the
story
not because of any underlying reason
because they don't like the story
therefore you cannot disseminate the
story
and they particularly don't like the
story because they are afraid that if
joe biden
were to see that story disseminated on
facebook
that maybe joe biden and his democratic
friends might regulate facebook
okay this is exactly the accusation that
the left has been making about trump
and companies like facebook is that
because trump has had conversations with
mark zuckerberg that zuckerberg
was was somehow biasing the algorithm at
facebook to benefit trump
this is all part of the leftist bullcrap
narrative that they pushed in 2016 after
hillary clinton a horrible candidate
lost to maybe the most unpopular
candidate of all time donald trump
they pushed a narrative that was because
facebook taken over by russian bots
had somehow changed the outcome of the
election and then they decided to
pressure
facebook into changing its policies so
basically these social media companies
are so afraid of democrats they will
voluntarily do what democrats want so
democrats don't come after them
this is a blackmail routine by democrats
against social media it's an inside
outside job because so many members of
the media love
facebook censoring material and it's
facebook an inside job and twitter of an
inside job
when top democrats at these places
decide that it is time to shut down
material
there's a baseline agreement between
democrats the social media bros
and the and the journalists all of whom
are lying to you about their true agenda
none of them apparently care about
freedom of the press particularly the
journalists it's astonishing it's
astonishing
how little journalists care about
freedom of the press i mean they really
don't care about it
they hate it in fact they would love to
see many of them free speech cracked
down upon
by social media in the name of their
actual principles which are of the left
i'll bring you the details on this in
just one second because it's it's
horrifying
first let us talk about the fact that
you're spending too much money on your
cell phone bill you really are
if your cellular plan is with verizon at
t t-mobile you are paying way too much
for the exact same coverage you would be
getting right now
with pure talk look at your cell phone
bill where it shows data usage the
average person who switches to pure talk
is using less than four gigs of data a
month but the big carriers are charging
you for unlimited data which is like
paying for an entire row on an airplane
but only needing
one seat well that's how pure talk saves
the average person over 400 bucks a year
on their wireless service they give you
unlimited talk text and two gigs of data
all for just 20 bucks a month
what happens if you go over on data
usage well they still don't charge you
for it
folks switching to peer talk it's the
easiest decision you will make today
grab your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do
you'll save 50 off your first month dial
pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro
puretalk it's simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now dial pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
pound two fifty say keyword
ben shapiro there is no reason at all
for you to be spending too much on your
cell phone bill unless you're addicted
to spending too much money or something
go check out pure talk usa today
dialpound250 say ben shapiro save 50
off your first month okay so here is
what happened in detail
so twitter put out a notice
okay they said that in line with our
hacked materials policy
as well as our approach to blocking urls
we are taking action to block any links
of
or images to the material in question on
twitter is what a twitter spokesperson
told national review
twitter's hack materials policy states
it does not permit the use of our
services to directly distribute content
obtained through hacking that contains
private information
may put people in physical harm or
danger or contains trade secrets
though the platform does currently allow
leaked and hacked material from other
sources including wikileaks to be shared
the platform said the policy applied in
this case due to concerns about the lack
of authoritative reporting
in regards to the origins of the
material okay so let's just be straight
the new york post reports that there is
a laptop hunter biden who is a
who is a dope addict okay hunter biden
who is a drug addict and a and a
derelict
left his computer at this computer
repair store according to the new york
post he just left it there he never
picked it up he was filled with all
sorts of stuff
the guy opened up the computer he saw
this foreign material apparently he
called it into the fbi he made a copy of
it because
he seems to be something of a conspiracy
theorist and then he handed it over to
rudy giuliani
right that seems to be the way that this
got to the new york post but according
to
twitter they suspect that this is
actually russian disinformation that it
was hacked material by the russians
handed over so a couple of things one
since when has russian disinformation
been banned
seriously from twitter russian
disinformation is not banned from
twitter
the entire russian collusion scandal was
essentially russia
the christopher steele dossier was all
russian disinformation did twitter take
down a single story on it
how about the idea that twitter takes
down hacked material
really how much hex material did they
take down from like edward snowden
or wikileaks the answer is none they
didn't take down
any of that stuff right so this is just
crap when they
by the way twitter's policy is even
broader than that
first of all and they say there's a lack
of authoritative reporting based on what
based on what lack of authoritative
reporting again the thing had not been
fact checked yet
it's not as though there was a fact
check of the story and people said okay
well this story is falling apart
and so twitter took it down instead
preemptively twitter took it down and
banned you from disseminating the
article so let's just be straight about
this a month and a half ago there was a
story from the atlantic claiming that
donald trump routinely went around to
military cemeteries and said bad things
about dead soldiers it turns out that
every element of that story
fell apart there were people on the
record denying the story every source in
that story was unnamed
every element of that story so far as
i'm aware has now been debunked by
people who are on site
okay there is yet to be a single named
source in that story not
one link from the atlantic was removed
on that basis
you know how many stories we've seen
like that how many links went out there
about how the russians were paying
taliban fighters to kill american
soldiers and trump was ignoring it and
then it turned out that that story kind
of fell apart did any of those links
come down
no not one of those links came down okay
so there's no neutral standard here this
is just a bunch of crap
it's just a bunch of crap twitter
originally suggested not kidding that
their rationale here was hacking
there is no evidence that the thing was
hacked in the first place
again the story in the new york post
suggests it was not about hacking the
story in the new york post suggests that
it was a laptop that was physically
turned over to rudy giuliani and to the
fbi
okay so then later in the day twitter
tried to release a second
explanation here was their second
explanation
we want to provide much clear
much-needed clarity around the actions
we've taken with respect to two new york
post articles that were first tweeted
this morning
the images contained in the articles
include personal and private information
like email addresses and phone numbers
which violate our rules
okay um no this is not correct okay
people disseminated those
images all day yesterday on twitter
their accounts were not taken down the
link was blocked
and here's where we get here's where it
gets good as noted this morning we also
currently view materials included in the
articles as violation of our hacked
materials policies
commentary on or discussion about hacked
materials such as articles that cover
them but do not include or link to the
materials themselves
aren't a violation of this policy our
policy only covers links to or images of
hacked materials themselves again there
is no evidence at this point that this
is hacked material
hunter biden is an idiot so he left a
laptop at a computer repair store
beyond that hacked mate okay so then it
gets even worse okay you ready
here's where it gets wild twitter says
the policy established in 2018
prohibits the use of our service to
distribute content obtained without
authorization
we don't want to incentivize hacking by
allowing twitter to be used as
distribution for possibly illegally
obtained materials okay here's where we
are
off the rails now okay hacking is a very
specific charge which is that somebody
illegally
violated they went they violated the law
they hacked into your computer they took
materials twitter doesn't want that
distributed
forget about the fact they've not evenly
applied this policy obviously
they literally say that their policy
prohibits the use of our service
to distribute content obtained without
authorization let's see
can we think of a story in which content
was distributed
without it was obtained and distributed
without authorization can we think of
twitter in the past
having distributed those sorts of
stories and played them up what if
i told you that like a week and a half
ago twitter went
naked crazy on the trump tax
returns how do you think
those came out do you think trump just
decided to release those do you think an
authorized person decided to release
those
how exactly did those materials come out
i mean i'm told by twitter that they
prohibit the use of their service to
distribute content obtained without
authorization who authorized the release
of those materials anybody
anybody bueller bueller
okay i can name a half dozen stories off
the top of my head
in which twitter allowed distribution to
not only allow the distribution
push the distribution right propped it
up on their twitter trends
i'm old enough to remember when there
was this tape of mitt romney talking
about 47
of americans who wouldn't vote for him
that was tape that was not authorized
it was jimmy carter's grandson who took
a tape was that authorized material had
mitt romney authorized the release of
that material
how about pictures that are not
authorized of people who have not given
their permission that's every public
photo in a public place
okay this is this is insane this has
nothing to do with the neutral policy
nothing to do i mean it's a clown show a
total ridiculous clown show so trump's
tax returns apparently
that's authorized that's all
authorization but
you know but but this was completely
unauthorized
crazy crazy okay so how does
jack jack dorsey dumbass head of twitter
guy who donated 10 million dollars to
ibram kendy so he could feel not racist
while getting bit by mosquitoes in
malaysia or something how does jack
dorsey respond to this quote
our communication around our actions on
the new york post article was not great
and blocking url sharing via tweet or dm
with zero
context as to why we're blocking is
unacceptable the problem is not your
communication strategy
the problem is that you blocked the
material without any actual rationale as
to why you would block this material as
opposed to
any other leaked material
virtually every major story is an
unauthorized leak of information
every bombshell story is an unauthorized
leak how many off how many authorized
leaks have there been from the federal
government
in the recent past every story involving
andrew mccabe leaking to the wall street
journal which as it turns out got his
his pension cancelled i believe
anime those stories were not taken down
by twitter every unauthorized leak from
the mueller
probe were any of those taken down by
twitter of course not
there's only one story that has been
overtly banned by twitter and that is a
story involving hunter and joe biden
hmm i wonder why it could be that
why is it that trump's tax returns
perfectly oh they were authorized now
i'm
now i'm to believe that they were
authorized
a twitter is a leftist garbage heap you
should go check out parlor today parlor
is a good alternative to twitter
is not going to ban people or
informational dissemination based on
pure political content
okay go check out power alert today it's
run by a bunch of my
friends and colleagues we're worth
establishing an account
okay it wasn't just twitter it was also
facebook and facebook's standard is even
more
insane even crazier okay we'll get to
that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
you don't have time to go down to the
post office right now you don't want to
be waiting in line at the post office
the post office offers a lot of great
services but if you can make a routine
task easier in business
you ought to do it it'll save you time
it'll save you money well stamps.com can
make that happen
for you with stamps.com you can print
postage on demand you can avoid going to
the post office
you'll save money with discounted rates
you can't even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges here at
dailywear we've used stamps.com since
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings all the mailing and shipping
services you need
directly to your computer in the comfort
of your home or office
whether you're a small business sending
invoices or an online seller shipping
out products
or you're just working from home and you
need to mail stuff stamps.com can handle
it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it once your mail is
ready just leave it for your mail
carrier schedule a pickup or
drop it off in the mailbox it is indeed
that simple and again you get those
great discounts you get five cents off
every stamp up to 62
off usps and ups shipping rates right
now my listeners get a special offer
it includes a four week trial plus free
postage and digital scale no long-term
commitment just go to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro that is
stamps.com
enter code shapiro okay so it's not just
twitter facebook
also did this facebook censored this and
downgraded it
before a fact check before a fact check
they didn't wait
for their vaunted outside fact checkers
to fact-check the story
they preemptively prevented you from
disseminating the story
okay andy stone who is a former
democratic operative
he he now works in a high level over at
facebook
he tweeted this out yesterday very early
yesterday morning
quote well i will intentionally not link
to the new york post i want to be clear
that this story is eligible to be fact
checked by facebook's third-party
fact-checking partners
in the meantime we're reducing its
distribution on our platform
that's insane that's crazy
he says this is part of our standard
process to reduce the spread of
misinformation
we temporarily reduce distribution
pending fact check or review
okay so go back to that first tweet for
a second because you got to break this
down so their new standard is
if andy stone doesn't like it at
facebook they will preemptively
ban the distribution of the information
waiting for a fact checker to do their
dirty work and call the thing false
that's nuts it has not been fact checked
yet the story came out
that morning he literally says that the
story is eligible to be faction every
story is eligibly fact checked on
facebook
every one of the daily wire stories is
fact-checked basically by politifact and
half of them are lied about overtly by
politifact
again it is a sin for facebook to
outsource its fact-checking
to overtly political sites like
politifact they purport to be
non-leftists they are leftist in the
extreme but that's not
even that's not even what this is this
isn't that they outsourced a fact check
of a true statement to a leftist source
who declared it false
this is we didn't even bother to wait
for the fact checkers we are banning the
story
before it is fact checked why because
andy stone and the democrats are
suspicious of a story that makes joe
biden look bad
he refers to the facebook policy there
right he says well you know this is in
line with our normal facebook policy
which is that we will reduce
distribution of a story
pending a fact check here's the actual
facebook policy quote
we're working to take faster actions to
prevent misinformation from going viral
especially given that quality reporting
and fact checking takes time
in many countries including in the us if
we have signals that a piece of content
is false
we temporarily reduce its distribution
pending review by a third party fact
checker
what were the signals that this piece of
content is false
any well what really what i
have yet to hear a single aspect of the
core story demand
the washington post hilariously tried to
debunk
something that actually is not the core
elements of the story
right they say well you know there's no
evidence that joe biden actually got
victor shoken fired in order to protect
hunter that is not the core element of
the story the core elements of the story
is the emails and the meeting
none of that was debunked not a word of
it so what was
facebook's preliminary information
signaling that the piece of content was
false what did biden denied it
because trump has denied a thousand
stories that facebook has not
preliminarily taken down this happens
all the time
every single day there is a story in
which the new york times reports
something that the trump administration
says is false
has facebook ever once preemptively
removed the link or downgraded the
distribution
of course not of course not it's
perfectly obvious what happened here
democrats
decided they didn't like the story
democrats in social media decided that
they didn't like the story
and journalists cheered this is the part
that's maybe the most sickening of all
is that our journalistic establishment
is very much in favor of censorship they
love it
they love it they think that trump is a
threat to the republic they think trump
is a threat to the press
the press is a threat to the press our
journalistic bettors
are a threat to the press it's jackasses
and morons like kara swisher at the new
york times or kevin roose at the new
york times or charlie warzell at the new
york times who spends each and every day
trying to not so subtly urge social
media to crack down
on dissemination of any information that
they personally do not like
there is a reason that ben rhodes a man
who overtly acknowledges who overtly
acknowledges that he created a
journalistic echo chamber to promote
falsehoods about his iran deal
he tweeted out the republican freakout
over not being able to spread
disinformation unchecked
demonstrates why you should not be able
to spread this information unchecked
they know they have no political
viability without the capacity to spread
lies
i have a question what says that this is
this information
what there's no information here what
ben rhodes means is information i don't
like is disinformation and it should not
spread unchecked
and therefore i want all of this shut
down and it was not just ben rhodes
it was a bunch of journalists it was
charlie warzell at the new york times
yesterday well you know just because
just because there's a freedom of the
press to print doesn't mean there should
be freedom of distribution it doesn't
mean we should let the social media do
all this stuff
one there are a couple of underlying
factors here one members of the press
are generally of the left they do not
want people who are of the right to have
the ability to distribute their material
there have been 1 000 stories about how
my outlet the daily wire is successful
on social media on twitter on facebook
and the implication is of course that we
are doing something deeply corrupt with
facebook we're currently being
downgraded by facebook on a bullcrap
fact track okay so that's not true
beyond that
the basic notion which is that the right
wing is being specifically
pulled out and and chosen by facebook
that is a lie they know it is a lie they
continue to promote the lie
anyway the media keeps saying over and
over and over
that engagement on the right is really
high and it's true engagement on the
right is
really high so for example in august
newswhip announced that the daily wire
my outlet had for the second month in a
row taken the top spot for total
engagements
amassing 104.9 million engagements over
the course of the month
two other explicitly conservative sites
the blaze and breitbart made it into the
top ten
so this was supposed to be big news okay
but here's the thing if you add up all
of the engagements of the three
conservative sites
you find that they collectively racked
up 187.8 million engagements
over the course of the month that is
just under a third of the 587.8 million
total engagements among the top 10.
if you expand the list to the top 25
news publishers for august you'll find
just three more self-styled conservative
sites western journal cns news
and conservative opinion the total
engagements represented by that group of
sex 257.4 million engagements
that ex that gives explicitly
conservative sites just 27
of total engagements in the top 25. if
you include fox news
daily mail and the new york post you'll
find right leading sites account for
less than half of engagements produced
by facebook's top
25 sites and if you look at the data
from previous months
you will see that it completely falls
apart
you know that in previous months our
reach has not been quite as great as
that
and it's not just which sites get the
most engagement it's which sites have
the most reach
in other words which sites posts are
seen by the most users
there too left-leaning and mainstream
media outlets outperform conservative
sites
a point highlighted by facebook's head
of news feed john hageman in july
in response to the new york times tech
columnist kevin roos a steady stream
of facebook themes tweets trying to
suggest that conservatives should be
shut down on social media
hegemon suggested that roose and others
are missing the proper metric
according to hegemon a more accurate
metric for understanding what news
people
see on facebook is reach or the number
of people who saw a link in their news
feed
hegemon shared a list of links that had
the widest reach on facebook compared
with the post with the highest
engagement on the same day
on july 5th for example the post with
the highest engagement came from
franklin graham
me breitbart for america and cnn by
contrast the links with the widest reach
that day
came from the la times msnbc ranker
buzzfeed and abc news
so they're just lying about the idea
that conservatives have this outsized
advantage on facebook it is just not
true
but this is all part of the generalized
journalistic rage
that the right wing even exists there's
an attempt by mainstream media and
left-wing outlets to shut down
dissemination on the right this does not
exist on the right
it does not exist on the right there is
no one on the right who believes that
social media should shut down
nbc the new york times abc news
huffington post
buzzfeed or any other leftist outlet
there's no one
on the right who said that the new york
times should not have the right
to post that trump tax return stuff on
facebook
we may have objected to the story we may
have asked whether it was criminally
obtained
but nobody suggested that facebook
should take it down only the left and
our journalistic bettors are saying this
our journalists do not care about the
first amendment
they object to the first amendment the
allows people to disseminate information
they don't like and so what they are
attempting to do
is use non-governmental mechanisms in
order to reduce distribution for
material they don't like
that is what you are seeing in action
right now social media being used as an
informal mechanism
of creating a bottleneck in the
informational dissemination system
and one of the beauties of the internet
is that it broke the mainstream media
domination that was one of the beauties
of the internet
and now mainstream media are pissed and
what they would like to do is reduce
distribution for everybody else via the
social media
networks where everybody where everybody
gathers
and make it so that you are back to only
having access to stories
that the left wing approves of and only
outlets that the mainstream media like
they're trying to re-establish monopoly
via facebook via twitter via the social
media sites
the predictable effect of this should
that people should be rushing away from
those sites
on mass to sites that are actually going
to allow you to see the things that you
want to see
as i say this is purely political it is
obviously political
and sora bamari the editor of the new
york post
op ed page right this is what
totalitarianism looks like in our
century not men in dark and cells
driving screws under fingernails but
silicon valley dweebs are moving from
vast swathes of the internet
a damaging expose on their preferred
presidential candidate
he says you know the standards that
they're using they've never been applied
to any of these other stories
remember when four cnn reporters claimed
in june 2017 james comey was about to
dispute in congressional testimony
trump's claim the fbi director had
reassured the president he wasn't under
investigation
comey didn't do it did twitter and
facebook censor the story nope
remember when the guardian concocted a
story about trump campaign chief paul
manafort
and julian assange meeting at ecuador's
embassy in london the meeting didn't
happen did facebook or twitter block the
story
nope you can still post it remember when
the atlantic published a several
thousand word story suggesting that jeff
sessions had lied when he said
he didn't meet the russian ambassador as
a team trump surrogate but as a routine
member
but as a routine matter the mueller
report debunked the atlantic decisively
is that atlantic story blocked as
misinformation nope
okay it's perfectly obvious what
happened here and the disgusting and
stomach churning part of this
is that it is not only approved by
democrats which you would expect but by
the social media companies themselves
and the democrats within
and it is approved by the journalistic
institutions who supposedly stand
squarely in favor of free speech
the first amendment nonsense they do not
they simply do not
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because this is the scandal of
the campaign
whatever else was happening in the
campaign the thing that's going to
affect you beyond the campaign is this
okay because we all engage with these
social media sites
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that and with all of these
scary things happening
this year policy genius would like to
mark halloween by making something less
scary
life insurance shopping for life
insurance can seem like a daunting task
policy genius makes it easy they combine
a cutting edge insurance marketplace
with help from licensed experts to save
you time and save you money
right now you could save 50 or more by
using policy genius to compare life
insurance
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for more than a decade those
savings really start to add up here's
how it works first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find your best price policy
genius will compare policies starting at
as little as one dollar a day you might
even be eligible to skip that in-person
medical exam
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape the best part they work for you
not the insurance company so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they'll go ahead and
take care of everything
for you that kind of service has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
over 1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google as well so if
you need life insurance
head on over to policygenius.com right
now to get started you could say 50
or more by comparing quotes if you're a
responsible person if you have
dependents
you do in fact need life insurance and
you're a fool not to obtain it via
policygenius.com head on over to
policygenius.com
get a competitive quote and then get the
life insurance you and your family
require when it comes to insurance it's
nice
and important to get it right okay we'll
get to
more of the media cheering on the
crackdown
on free dissemination of information and
by the way it's not just twitter and
facebook it is now amazon as well
get some more of this in just one second
first if you have not already heard
daily wires old glory daily wear
baseball bat it's back
the clue bat this is our limited edition
handcrafted custom painted baseball bat
emblazoned with that magical daily wire
logo so every hit you make
will be a home run since we relaunched
on monday they're almost all sold out
today is the last day they'll be
available you can still get yours if you
hurry text the keyword baseball to 83400
purchase
your bat today if you haven't already
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe to become a member today
members get our articles yeah free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show exclusive
readers past content available only to
daily wire members if you're considering
an all-access membership
you get to join us on all access live
every night for online and live stream
discussions
you also get not one but two leftist
tiers tumblers with your membership
as well as early sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wear products let me
tell you
in this coming year we're going to have
so much amazing content for our
subscribers i cannot even begin to
describe the magic that shall befall you
when you become a member at
dailywire.com
subscribe go check it out right now
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
there's a reason republicans are
fighting mad senator josh halley of
missouri who's been calling for
regulation of facebook and twitter and
social media in general
he is now demanding answers as to why
facebook and twitter limited the ability
to read that new york post piece
and he has now asked the federal
election commission to express his
concern
regarding what he described as
unprecedented suppression from big tech
he said the post reporting has
understandably attracted substantial
public discussions
countless americans have sought to
discuss and debate that article but two
social media platforms
have engaged in unprecedented
suppression of public discussion of that
article
the conduct does not merely censor the
core political speech of ordinary
americans though it definitely does that
twitter and facebook's conduct also
appears to constitute constitute a clear
violation
of federal campaign finance law federal
law prohibits any corporation from
making a contribution to a federal
candidate
for office he's saying this is basically
an in-kind contribution by the media i
mean by that standard frankly
that is the that is the democratic slash
mainstream media every single day donald
trump commented on this in a rally in
iowa last night going hard after the
social media companies as well he should
here he was yesterday
false and libelous stories every day
false and libelous stories and they knew
they were false too
they knew they were false they were
never taken down
by twitter or facebook or the mainstream
media never once
yet with biden today they take negative
postdown almost before they even go up
they're trying to protect them they're
trying to protect biden
he is not wrong about this and he is
right to call it out and he should
continue to call all of this out
by the way there's a follow-up story
today from the new york post on those
hunter biden emails
it turns out that hunter biden was also
picking up bags of cash over in china
which is exciting stuff apparently he
had been offered something like 10
million dollars
annually 100 biden
hal uh by by a vanish chairman of a
company called cefc
yi zhang ming biden was supposed to be
paid 10 million dollars a year for quote
introductions alone
yeah don't worry he wasn't trafficking
on daddy's name meanwhile by the way
it's not just facebook and twitter
cracking down on dissemination of
material that they don't like
amazon has now canceled shelby steel so
shelby steele who is an incredible
thinker
he's the author of just an incredibly
insightful book about race relations in
america called white guilt among other
things he has a new documentary out it's
called what killed michael brown
amazon has turned down distribution of
the documentary why because shelby
steele takes the perspective
that correctly michael brown was not in
fact murdered in cold blood by a police
officer that in fact there are deep
and abiding problems with regard to
black crime rates for example
the subject racial relations is a major
fault line in the presidential election
there's a reason why the steel's
scheduled their film for release on
october 16th
the movie however does not fit the
dominant black lives matter narrative
and so amazon rejected it for its
streaming service he can't even obtain
it there so amazon will give you
basically softcore pornography if you
would like to buy it
but if you want to pay a couple of bucks
to watch shelby steals movie on amazon
you cannot amazon inform the steals
their film is quote not eligible for
publishing because it doesn't meet prime
video's content
quality expectations the movie is well
made i've seen it
it ain't about that it's about it's
about the fact that shelby steele
does not abide by the black lives matter
narrative that america is systemically
racist
and that all problems in the black
community spring from
the evils of the united states i mean
that is
so that's an amazing story it's amazing
now i i want to discuss
at a little bit of length again how the
media have reacted to all of these
giant crackdowns by these social media
companies
and by our major corporations and the
answer is
that they are fine with it they love it
i have yet to see a lot of mainstream
media reporters or journalists or even
opinion columnists
saying that it is bad that the social
media companies are cracking down on
information
they do not like in fact today over at
new york times magazine
there is a piece by emily bazelon
suggesting that free speech
is bad that the first amendment needs to
stop
this is literally the piece in the new
york times magazine
this weekend it's all about how free
speech is a threat to our democracy
the basic idea here is that because free
speech allows for the possibility of
misinformation
free speech is bad according to
emily bazelon she says the conspiracy
theories the lies the distortions the
overwhelming amounts of information the
anger encoded in it these all serve to
create chaos and confusion
and make people even non-partisans
exhausted skeptical cynical about
politics
the spewing of falsehoods isn't meant to
win any battle of ideas its goal is to
prevent the actual battle from being
fought by causing us to simply give up
the problem isn't just the internet a
working paper from the berkman client
center for internet and society at
harvard released earlier this month
found that effective disinformation
campaigns are often an elite driven
mass media-led process in which social
media played only a secondary and
supportive role
trump's election put him in position to
operate directly through fox news and
other conservative media outlets like
rush limbaugh's talk radio show which
have come to function in effect as a
party press the harvard researchers
found
a false story about democrats plotting a
coup spread through a typical feedback
loop
links from fox news hosts and other
right-wing figures lined with trump like
dan bongino
often dominate the top links in
facebook's news feed for likes comments
and shares in the united states
though fox news is far smaller than
facebook the social media platform has
helped fox attain the highest weekly
reach
offline and online combined of any
single news source in the united states
according to a 2020 report by reuters
institute again this is all tied into
the new york times's attempt to prevent
social media from disseminating
information they do not like better to
force social media to shut off those
spigots
better to cut against the first
amendment directly
emily bazlon just goes right for it so
points for honesty to emily bazelon in
new york times magazine
she's not just ripping on social media
and saying social media should crack
down on free speech she's saying we
should all crack down on free speech
the government should rewrite its own
doctrines on free speech
according to emily bazelon quote it's an
article of faith in the united states
that more speech is better
and that government should regulate it
as little as possible but increasingly
scholars of constitutional law
as well as social scientists are
beginning to question the way we have
come to think about the first
amendment's guarantee of free speech
they think our formulations are
simplistic and especially inadequate for
our era
censorship of external critics by the
government remains a serious threat
under authoritarian regimes but in the
united states and other democracies
there's a different kind of threat
which may be doing more damage to the
discourse about politics news and
science
it encompasses the mass distortion of
truth and overwhelming waves of speech
from extremists
that smear and distract do you
understand the insane danger that emily
bazelon is proposing as policy here
she is saying that because you get to
speak freely
you might say something emily bazlon
doesn't like and therefore that emily
bazlon categorizes
as speech from an extremist that smears
and distracts
she's saying there is a bigger threat
from you speaking freely than there is
from the government controlling speech
that is a patently absurd absurd
disgusting
perspective on your rights as an
individual american citizen
it's disgusting it really is it is
top-down fascism
it is a suggestion that you cannot be
trusted with your own liberty therefore
the government will stop you
from speaking freely or should stop you
from speaking freely or should prevent
the dissemination of information that
ben rhodes and emily bazelon and your
bettors of the new york times don't like
this concern spans the ideological
spectrum along with disinformation
campaigns there's a separate problem of
troll armies a flood of commenters
often propelled by bots that aim to
discredit or to destroy the reputation
of disfavored speakers and to discourage
them from speaking again says jack
goldsmith a conservative law professor
at harvard
this tactic may be directed by those in
power either way it's often grimly
effective at muting critical voices
and yet as tim wu a progressive law
professor at colombia points out in the
same book the use of speech as a tool to
suppress speech is by its nature
something very challenging for the first
amendment to deal with
these scholars argue something that may
seem unsettling to americans that
perhaps our way of thinking about free
speech is not the best way
at the very least we should understand
it isn't the only way other democracies
in europe and elsewhere have taken a
different approach
despite more regulations on speech these
countries remain democratic
in fact they've created better
conditions for their citizenry to sort
what's true from what's not and to make
informed decisions about what they want
their societies to be
here in the united states meanwhile we
are drowning in lies
so presumably she would like the sort of
hate speech regulation you see in
scotland where if you're a religious
person you can be thrown in jail
depending on what you have to say about
lgbt issues
presumably she would like the sort of
hate speech regulations you see across
europe
where if you say something quote unquote
islamophobic
you could theoretically be prosecuted
your outlet could be shut down
okay this is what the left in the united
states would like
now the aclu used to say that they would
fight to the death for your right to say
something with which they disagreed
now the aclu and the entire left its
infrastructure say precisely the
opposite
they want the government to crack down
on speech they do not like they're
becoming clear
and open about this emily bazelon's
piece here it's just the tip of the
spear okay this is this has been going
around and left his circles for a while
there was a new york times
piece maybe a year ago year and a half
ago by an obama administration official
arguing the exact same thing we should
pursue hate speech regulations in the
united states that prevent the
dissemination of information
and perspectives that members of the
left do not like
emily bazelon says facts and
transparency are the intended pillars of
the modern first amendment since the
nation's founding the constitution is
guaranteed the government shall make no
law abridging freedom of speech over the
press
for more than a century however these
limits on the state's power were worth
little
from 19 from 1798 to 1801 more than two
dozen people including several newspaper
editors were prosecuted by the
administration of john adams under the
alien and sedition act
prosecutors were also jailed for
criticizing the government during world
war one
okay this is hilarious she's now
defending some of the darkest periods
for free speech in america's history
most people who study the constitution
think the aliens edition acts were bad
think that woodrow wilson cracking down
on the dissemination of ideas during
world war one was bad emily bazelon says
well maybe it's good
maybe it's good so again this is what
happens
when you believe that you have a sheer
majority and through the power of
compulsion you can get people
to shut up this is the attitude of many
in media
do not make the mistake of thinking that
just because there are people in media
who purport to believe in free speech
that that is the dominant ideology
inside the media it is not and there are
many pieces of evidence for this that
are happening in real time not just the
emily bazlon
article so yesterday maggie haberman
tweeted out that new york post piece
apparently that was evil
she captioned her post with an excerpt
from the post piece both the computer
and the hard drive were seized by the
fbi in december after shop's owner says
he alerted the feds to their existence
okay and everybody on the left went nuts
journalists why nots how could maggie
haberman
tweet out a link from a major american
newspaper alleging a thing about joe
biden
how could that happen kimberly johnson
who is some sort of left-wing author
she writes for huffington post for
example she tweeted out what is wrong
with you
you know they're calling you magda
haberman right and you deserve it shame
on you
we saw other outlets complaining
about how it was terrible that maggie
haberman had had the
had had the temerity to tweet out a link
how dare maggie haberman
okay kevin cruz who is just another one
of these uh these joke commentators
he uh he wrote a really kind of crappy
piece for the uh 1619 project
so kevin cruz he put out a tweet about
maggie haberman
that said quote why are you amplifying
this pathetic hit
how dare you tweet out a link she
literally just tweeted out a link
okay then later she followed up on it by
trying to walk it back she said things
that are sketchy in the new york post
story on hunter biden
why wasn't this in ron johnson report if
it's been in possession for a while when
did giuliani acquire it giuliani has
been everywhere on the
uh on this but this has been kicking
around since late last year and
unreleased
until now okay the
the the david corn meanwhile suggested
that this was
disinformation again members of the
media very
angry at maggie haberman because again
in the end in the end all that matters
is that the information disseminated is
something that members of the left don't
like so maggie haberman is bad
kevin cruz my goodness okay another
example of this
nbc staffers are fighting mad because
nbc scheduled a trump town hall tonight
so there's supposed to be a debate
tonight the commission on presidential
debate which apparently is just
another organ of the left there's no
other way for me to interpret
their cancellation of a debate a week in
advance because trump had coveted
i don't get it they literally did not
consult with a single member of the
medical community apparently they just
decided we can't have an in-person
debate
how stupid was this policy tonight trump
is going to be
he's been doing open rallies with the
with the advice of his doctors that he
is no longer capable of transmitting
covet 19. so joe biden is going to do a
town hall
on abc nbc is scheduling a counter town
hall
with donald trump and nbc staffers are
mad
instead of nbc being like oh you know
what it's kind of newsworthy the
president of the united states doing a
town hall
and on the other network they have the
candidate for president doing a town
hall so why the hell not
instead nbc staffers are angry they're
dismayed
over a dozen staffers from nbc msnbc and
cnbc have now expressed anger over this
decision
that report comes just several hours
after nbc announced the town hall
and abc indicated the network will not
move its scheduled event
with biden why are they angry like what
is the idea of them being
they're angry because they don't want
people to remove attention from
joe biden that's really what this is
about so they're angry at their own
network
for doing a newsworthy thing
broadcasting a town hall with trump
they're angry at their own network these
are news people supposedly
and you see this again across the left
so wolf blitzer we played you yesterday
this this
amazing exchange between wolf blitz and
nancy pelosi and which pelosi absolutely
loses whatever is left of her mind and
starts yelling at wolf blitzer
suggesting we feed poor people you're
mean all because wolf blitzer asked for
a very simple question namely why don't
you sign off on a 1.8
trillion dollar relief package in the
middle of covid pelosi couldn't answer
it for 14 minutes so instead she
she decided to berate wolf blitzer
here's what that sounded like yesterday
no you know them i'm i'm just saying i
represent them and we know them
as we say we know them we represent them
don't let the perfect be the enemy of
the good as they say
nowhere near madame speaker always the
case but we're not even close to the
good
all right let's see what happens because
every day is critically critically
important thanks so much for joining us
your sensitivity to our constituents
needs
i am sensitive to them because i see
them on the street begging for food
begging for money now speaker thank you
we feed them
we feed them yeah she is she was awful
right she was awful so how did members
of the left respond to nancy pelosi
being offline wolf blitzer they got
angry at wolf blitzer
here was joy behar yesterday on the view
yelling at wolf blitzer for having to
merit to ask nancy pelosi a simple
question
wolf i love wolf who doesn't love wolf
we all love wolf but he was out of line
he doesn't know what's going on behind
closed doors he's not in on the deal
you know see if you're in front of the
camera the democrats have a real
long-term deal going on and we all know
we're going to be in this for another
year we all know that
where's the money for a year that's the
question and so trump so
we calm down and let nancy do a job
okay absolutely absolutely crazy but
this is the attitude
of many members of your traditional left
you know nancy pelosi has to do her job
stop asking her tough questions
we don't we like joe biden don't print
any stories about joe biden social media
should stop conservatives from being
able to disseminate information or they
should be downgraded
as bad sites because partisan fact
checkers have downgraded them
we are in a war of information of the
ability to even disseminate the
information
and um that war just got hot it was cold
it has now gotten
extremely extremely hot these social
media platforms they better
get right with the first amendment they
better get right with principles of free
speech and dissemination of information
or both the government is going to come
after them from both sides
and other outlets are going to come
after them and and they absolutely
should all ready we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowski our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clinton
you